Who would win: SCP-096, the Shy Guy, or a
nuclear bomb?
Nuclear bombs are some of the deadliest weapons
mankind has ever conceived - From their super-heated
blasts to their deadly radioactive fallout.
While it’s likely the initial blast would
sear off 096’s flesh with its extreme heat,
the Shy Guy’s true asset is its indestructible
skeleton.
If it survived the initial boom, its hyper-regenerative
ability would mean that it’s soon back on
its feet.
The jury is out on whether the radiation would
make any difference on that front, but even
if it did, could you imagine how even more
terrifying a skeleton-only version of the
Shy Guy stalking us would be?
Yikes!